hey what's up guys my name is jonah
welcome back to my game engine series
so last time we talked about how we
could clear specific frame buffer
texture attachments check out that video
if you haven't already
and today we are hopefully going to be
more or less concluding our whole mouse
picking
trilogy i think it's a trilogy might be
four episodes actually but um
basically uh we are going to be uh
making it so that instead of just
outputting
the value 50 every time we have to
render a pixel into that additional kind
of entity id buffer
we're going to actually hopefully be
able to
uh write in our actual entity id
into that texture so let's take a look
at how that's going to work
and get on with things okay so um
again last time just a little quick
little recap we basically
uh the state that we're at right now is
that if we look at this like pink cube
for example
we see the value negative one if our
mouse is over empty space because we're
now clearing
this specific texture attachment that's
holding this data to negative one at the
beginning of every frame
and then if we are over any
any entity and by the way even though
this looks like um
[Music]
uh even though this looks like it's uh
all one entity this is three different
entities left right and top and now we
have a fourth one you can see it's still
50
right so we are actually these are three
entities and they do have different ids
and you'll see that you'll see that in a
minute hopefully today
so how do we make that happen well
luckily for us
every single entity in hazel has an id
right if we go to the entity class we
can see that we have this ant
entity uh entity handle the type is ant
entity what is that let's take a look at
it
i always encourage you guys to actually
dig into the source code and see what
things actually are so it is an id
type what is an id type it's an ant id
type so much in direction i love it
i don't um that's the type
it's a uint32t so we are
what are we storing inside our um
buffer inside our frame buffer as a
texture attachment we are sawing
a gl red integer well that's the texture
format so basically it's a signed
integer
this is an unsigned integer that is a
signed integer we could have stored an
unsigned integer
i just thought i wanted negative one
just to be really clear for you guys
that negative one is not a valid entity
because zero is a valid nt so we
couldn't clear it with zero
so we have negative one when we have two
billion other ntids i think we'll be
fine ultimately but the point is it's an
integer
right this whole thing is an integer so
what we should be able to do
is for every entity that we render i
want to be able to
take this ant entity and somehow get it
into my shader
so at the end of the day really i just
output it here
so that should be my kind of end entity
value
right i want it to be over here instead
of the value 50.
so what are our options for this okay
well how do we get data to the shader in
the first place from c
plus plus well the simplest way is to
use uniforms right
but uniforms obviously have the
limitation of you can only set a uniform
in between draw calls you can't just set
uniforms
i don't know you can't like batch
together uniforms right like um
you can't set the same uniform for three
different it doesn't make sense right
it's not kind of like a pervertex thing
or a per object thing it's a per draw
call thing
and so um that doesn't really work for
us
at the moment without 2d rendering
because as you probably know
or you should know if you've been
following the series if we look at sin
um our renderer and the way the renderer
the way that rendering happens the way
that we actually draw a quad
i just completely it just lost where i
was
the way that we draw a quad is we call
this draw quad function which
does it draw the quad no it does not
draw the quad
it adds it to the vertex buffer
and then at the end of the frame when we
call end scene
and it calls flush and i pressed on the
wrong one uh
i was going so well um and i press
and uh we flush right then it does
a single draw call with all of our quads
in our scene so those four quads that
you saw with the white square as well as
the three kind of faces of the cube
that was a single draw call so there's
no way that we can actually add it as a
uniform
right what we can do instead and there's
a few different things you can do based
on like
if you're instancing you have ways to do
that if you're not interested in a few
different ways we could do it but
but the uh simplest way and the way that
we're going to be doing it is just
packing it into the vertex attributes
so what is what happens for every quad
developer powershell go away
what happens um to every quad that we
draw
we obviously set the vertex buffer to
particular values like the texture index
like the tiling factor
like the entity id as well now this has
one
extra little piece of limitation right
if you want to do this um and i want to
i want to mention a few things here
right but if you want to do this
the renderer now somewhat needs to be
aware of entities
is that acceptable well i see no reason
for it not to be acceptable i mean
some programmers like to hide things
from other things as a matter of
principle and that's fine i guess
but ultimately speaking this is renderer
2d
is hazel's renderer hazel works with
entities why would the two not know each
other right that that's not a huge deal
to me
right um tying things together and again
it might not even have to it's not like
i'm suddenly going to include
ant into renderer 2d all it needs is an
integer all i need to know is that hey
this quad that you're rendering i want
like an additional little payload on it
we'll call it the id of the draw
that's what i want you to do and that's
what i want you to output but the other
important thing here
to note is that
this is a editor thing this is not like
a runtime thing
right you you are not going to be
outputting an extra like you know you're
not going to have an extra frame buffer
attachment
just for entity ids in your shipped game
that could potentially be running on
like a phone
right that's just not going to happen
first of all that's a drain on
performance
but second of all unless your game
specifically needs mouse pit like little
tap to pick things which
isn't that uncommon um and if it does
need that maybe you would do it in a
different way anyway and maybe that
should be your job not the
not hazel's job unless you do like you
know you expose some kind of like um
you know raycast or something into the
3d world that maybe
you want to do there whatever but the
point is what we're writing here
specifically for the editor
so this does not need to exist
everywhere so what we end up doing
is first of all this shader we're
quickly realizing that this shader
is becoming an editor shader this isn't
a shader that we use
for like for shipped games because
having an additional attribute here
that's going to be our
entity id right this is what we're going
to do in fact we've just written that
code
this is not something that needs to ship
in a game right
and so um take just remember that
because a lot of people
you know are very quick to point out hey
man that's that's so inefficient that's
so i can't believe you're doing this
okay first of all show me how
inefficient it is show me some actual
profiling data and then maybe i'll
listen to you
but also hey man it's for the editor
it's for the editor
that you know this is hazel hazel's
gonna be a game engine you don't expect
unreal engine
4 or whatever to run on like you know
a chromebook or something like it
requires
a decent computer to run properly at
least right
so in other words my kind of allowance
for performance here is slightly
different my budget
will say in terms of frame time is
slightly different for hazel's editor
for hazelnut
than it is for hazel's run time which we
will refine
when we actually get to crossing that
bridge right so
it's a bit of a different story um
but also some things are just a lot
faster than people seem to think
and so people always like like saying oh
my gosh that takes
that's too slow it takes point five
milliseconds and it's like well dude
maybe that's something that i'm willing
to uh part with especially if it for
example only happens when we click or
something like that right because well
actually this isn't none of this is slow
really the the only slow part we've
really introduced
is this kind of read back which again as
i mentioned
only needs to happen when we click
technically unless you want to do
certain other things
anyway i don't want to get into some
rant again um but this is what we're
gonna do right
so how do we set this up and and i guess
the the primary reason i started talking
about this is because at the moment
right what we have
is we have a quad vertex
i'm gonna add a little section here that
says editor only and then i'm going to
add my
stid the reason is this doesn't need to
exist for the run time
but i don't want to start making like a
editor quad vertex and run time quad bit
i don't want to start doing that yet
right because when we actually get to
the runtime
that's when i want to start doing that
for now we're very much focused on the
editor
and the other thing is guess what you
can run the runtime with this and not
use it
right um unless you're actually getting
to the point where the performance is
really tight and you're like okay
what can i do let's try and optimize
this now then you can start being like
okay well this doesn't need to exist
let's remove it
from the runtime but um you know just uh
just just kind of a um just a just a
general word to everyone to just relax a
little bit because
uh you know it's okay it's okay we'll
remove slow things
when necessary don't worry i'm very
capable of optimizing code
okay so let's go into our drawing
functions
the big thing here though is again i
want to draw a quad i don't care about
the entity id
can you please just not record it that's
valid
um that's totally valid what i'm going
to do
is uh i'm going to uh
actually add a different set
of these functions there's a few ways
you could do this we could again add
another overload
to this function with like int ntid set
it to negative one
by default so that well you can print
negative one if you want it's like the
entity's not there it's like it's the
clear color
right but um
what i want to do is actually add a
different kind of entity right um
so and by different entities sorry i'm
in a different function so
one thing i started thinking of though
is we probably want to provide a default
for this
in fact we probably should provide a
default for everything we haven't
because they get they all get set
but this is something that maybe we
don't want to worry about right
i also don't really like the idea of
duplicating all of the functions either
um we could obviously create another
because we have a lot of these right
we've got one two three
vectors vectors um textures not
textures yes we just have that and then
again adding another set of these
overloads i really don't know if
if we should do it this way um
because what i was going to do off the
top of my head was just
draw quad entity or something like that
and that would include like entity id
um
which is fine but the only downside is
that
well yeah because the thing is like
again what this enables you to do is
first of all for things like
ui like you know you're not only drawing
quads
as part of like a sprite renderer
component
that's actually a good point though
right because specifically remember the
way that we're using this the way that
we're actually drawing this
maybe this is worth doing um
so let's go to like scene maybe this is
worth exploring
because um whilst i did write this code
on stream
ages ago during like a live stream that
i actually posted on youtube i'll have
it linked up there as well
i'll also get um that was uh
like that was more rough i wasn't really
refining the api i was just getting code
to work
so uh now i'm thinking more about the
design actually live during this episode
but you know we're passing in the
sprites
sprites are going to eventually have
textures
maybe it's worth having a function
called drawsprite
drawcord is fine right but
remember that there's there's there's
kind of different use cases for this
there's different contexts for all of
this
right on one hand draw quad can be used
for
rendering like you know things that have
nothing to do with entities things
that have nothing to do with your scene
like for example i want to render
a button i want to render something part
of the ui i want to render a little uh
i don't know like a little visualizer
for like a light or
like a little bounding box visualizer
that's not that's not that's just like a
debug thing right
but it's still like a 2d rendering in a
way right because it's a 2d primitive
so um these things don't necessarily
have
to do with a scene in hazel or like the
entity component system
so maybe we will actually use a function
called draw sprite
and the thing that makes this special
right this draw sprite function which
first of all let's go back to scene and
see how it's handled
so it actually does get taken in from a
transform right
um so we'll actually grab this draw
sprite will grab a transform
i don't want to use the position but the
thing that
this will actually do is
instead of taking all of this stuff in
i wanted to take in a sprite component
controversial perhaps because now
i'm using the entity component system i
mean this isn't really the
anti-component system
it's like the component but i'm using it
inside here
right now by the way this is going to
open the door to a lot of cool stuff
because at the moment i mean what are we
even doing man at the moment look at
this right
this can only draw a colored sprite we
can't
use textures we don't have tiling
factors
we don't have tint colors these are all
things that we can add to this bright
renderer component
and they will all be within here it will
take this in and then it can potentially
call one of these functions with the
right parameters
that's kind of what i'm doing in a way
but we'll probably end up writing our
own draws anyway
so inside here um let's move this over
here i'll do this
here so at the end we'll do our kind of
sprite stuff so sprite render component
now what else do we need
we do need the entity id right so i'm
just going to do
int entity id that's it so now we have a
function that we can run
instead of what we did uh with render a
draw quad
we're going to do renderer draw sprites
right because these are sprite renderer
components
uh transform get transform sprite
and then the object which guess what is
going to be just
entity cast into an int
that's it let's
get rid of this function now and let's
make that other function work
i think that's i actually really like
that idea to be honest
um i just came up with this now uh
but i like it so there you go sometimes
i do stuff live
um and i think this will work out well
so
let's go ahead and implement this
function um we'll have to also include
components here
i don't know if it's work it might be
worth like dividing components soon into
various header files just because we
don't necessarily need to include all
the components here
um wonders in scene
what's even in the components file
though it's just like
we don't we don't include um
oh we do include entity which probably
does include end
so we do include end technically but um
it's a scriptable entity includes entity
what's that even used for if there's a
native script component
we might move this stuff out of here
because yeah this is most of this stuff
is just
data right but this scriptable entity is
a bit more complex and it has an entity
which includes entity which includes and
so
it does end up being a little messy but
um we can deal with that later
all right so draw sprite is implemented
um how do we make that happen
so i mean ultimately at the end of the
day what are we trying to draw we're
trying to draw a non-textured sprite
with a transform which is just this
function at the moment
i'm going to copy this um and
uh yeah i'm not too happy about the
divergence
of code
[Music]
but the problem is that
the problem is that it actually has an
ntid but they all do at the moment
so maybe it's okay
maybe it's okay
okay let's take this away this should be
negative one anyway i don't know why
we're at zero um
let's take this away and let's do this
let's call draw
quad we're going to call that with
transform with src.color
um
so that's this one right it's got a
tiling factor it's got a tint color i'm
going to add an entity id
of negative one okay
two specifically but this takes in a
texture okay
ah because you can't have tin colors if
it's not that
okay it's okay we'll extend both of
these right with default parameters
so draw quad now we'll have an stid this
i think will only exist until we remove
this because we actually have a runtime
thing
but it's negative one anyway so you'll
be totally fine to do with
uh you'll you'll definitely be able to
do that this stuff with um
you know if you don't want to draw an
entity it's just going to set negative
one there which could be a bit of a
waste but
um i think it's okay these are kind of
the things that i think about
when i write code like this
okay so that's done uh and then we also
have our this one
which again will do the same thing
uh one more thing we have to do by the
way is actually add
it to here so shaded data type int
um i don't think we have any
we might have to do something special
here
because this layout may not be able to
deal with integers because there's
actually a special
attribute pointer function you have to
call for ins
um so vertex buffer where does this
happen though we have a layout
where we settle out in vertex array
yeah i think so okay
can someone please help me by the way
with
where this code came from because i
didn't write it and this
is like this is for like instance
rendering which we
have not covered yet so i don't know why
this is here to be honest
um so maybe someone will track that down
for me in the comments or on chat or
whatever
and let me know because i'm very
confused anyway um
so basically what we need to do for
these
right is something a little bit
different we need to use a different
function
um and i think for bull as well
be wrong whatever i'll just write the
code
and then you guys can fix it and pull
requests you know me
and that is basically we can enable it
right but
we use vertex attrib i pointer instead
right um there's no normalization for
this and i think that's the only
difference
right but this is used for integers not
for floating point types
um this is still fine i think there's
just some weird offset stuff going on
but
this is uh yeah everything else happens
the same so it's just important to use
that i function for integers
uh otherwise i don't think it'll work
properly so
back over here now so we've got
everything basically figured out now
right
we've made sure that inside renderer 2d
we're setting this as an int which it is
uh let me just line this up a bit
i always i never like it when stuff
isn't
well i don't know it's something i like
align everything it's just some things
because i'm definitely not one of those
alignment freaks where everything's
aligned but
some things like layouts and stuff i
like to have me and
i think i did the same thing with this
um
during the stream i aligned it and like
this as well you know that's why i have
the plus zero here
it just looks nice okay and it's easier
to read
so um we have the uh color
and then i think just the entity id and
that's all we need to call so that will
draw quad
um and then obviously what this at the
moment this function looks
fairly useless because it just does this
and we could have just done that from
scene
renderer but this function will actually
check to see if the sprite renderer
component uses a texture instead maybe
use a different one not a different
shader but
it'll pass that into the shader it'll
deal with tiling factors it'll do a lot
of stuff that's why it's here
okay um now we need to make the shader
do what it needs to do
so let's go into here and so position
color texture quad okay all this stuff
um so in entity id
let's do this let's do out flat
and i don't think it matters if it's
flat or not to be honest because
there's nothing there they're going to
be identical values just like with text
index for each uh
for each um vertex but anyway
so yeah we'll do that and then v
and cid is just simply what we'll output
here
and that actually should be it like if i
just
hit f5 i think we should just be good
we had some kind of issue here
so let's open pink cube
all right not quite so it's coming in as
negative one
oh actually i know no actually do i know
why
um let's go check it out so okay well
that's kind of promising in a way
negative one at least it's not like
garbage values probably just forgot
something to be honest
um so yeah draw quad takes in what now a
transform
a color and entity id which we are
providing here
into draw quad
and then that's what it's setting for
the quad vertices
so why is that not good
uh because that definitely should be
okay
um i may have just uh i mean is this the
only
point where we draw stuff
on update editor what's this function
arctic runtime i don't know
i don't even know if we're using that so
yeah we're just using the wrong function
here
i think that's the problem i don't know
yeah i don't know why we have a
yeah run time so that's because we added
the editor camera and then we also have
a camera in our scene and we
kind of can toggle between the two
technically all right so
um there you go so if you look at this
pixel data over here now
guess what when we move our mouse over
these three faces
you can see that it changes right
negative one
and then it's three it's zero and it's
two
pretty cool stuff right so the beauty of
this and i'll leave you with this before
we so we won't do the actual clicking
today
but i will leave you with this right
we'll be able to see what nc we're
hovering over
so when we actually have uh where do we
have all this stuff usually
so stats i mean we'll put it in stats
for now
but um maybe over here
um so let's do this
text harvard
t uh and then we'll do a little
s
so let's do this um
[Music]
when we read this pixel back instead of
pixel data
and instead of printing it i want to do
m
hovered entity
so we'll do entity and hover empty
we'll set it to that right uh and then
we'll
um that's actually an entity okay sure
so let's do
let's do that and then we'll do m hover
density equals
pixel data um we'll do
uh okay so
we'll do this if pixel data is negative
one
poverty um
equals nothing right um
[Music]
else
we'll do pixel data and
this scene so out of scene
is that a how does that work
handle and scene what's that
a ref saying so why are you upset
oh because i'm
handle nice and see
okay there we go right so um
i mean ultimately i'll combine this so
it's a little uh
bit more
so if it's negative one we'll do that
otherwise we'll do that
maybe that will make more sense
all right there we go so hover it nc
equals
either just a blanket like an an invalid
i guess empty entity or an entity that's
actually
real based on what the value is and then
what we can do here is basically say
that
if um so we'll do std string
i don't really need to do the sd string
but we'll do se string name equals
um none and then
if hover density we'll set name to
hover identity get component tag
components
and then dot tag
name dot c string all right
so now what should happen right is when
we hover our mouse
over an nc it should tell us what entity
we're hovering over over here so
hover density is none at the moment and
then if
i open up pink cube and i hover over a
particular entity you can see up here
hopefully it's very small maybe i'll uh
go to i'm gooey layer and actually just
make the font size larger which of
course we can't do it as we can
38 yeah let's do 38.
way bigger
so if i look at pink cube you can see
now that
depending on what i hover over it
actually says right left
top if i create a new entity and
give it a sprite render component and
i'll have to move it over here then you
can also see that as i hover
over it it says empty entity
because that's what it's called um
and then all those still work obviously
and everything is good
okay so hopefully uh
that all makes sense let's revet the
font size um next time all we're gonna
do is instead of printing this for
example
we can actually just go into like our
event
on event and add a little um mouse
clicked event and if we click
then well we've got the hovered entity
so technically with this system
we could just set the selected entity
and scene hierarchy panel to be the
hobbit entity
and our work is done um there are going
to be some bugs and some other things in
the way for example you'll note that
uh you know if i'm moving an entity i
probably don't want to select
other stuff just because my mouse
button's pressed or you know sometimes
when like for example i go to left and i
want to
drag right clicking in this case
shouldn't select the entity
because if i'm trying to drag this and i
click then technically the
this uh top face is in front and you can
see up here it says top
so i don't want that to be so there's a
lot of caveats to kind of figure out and
fix i guess with this but that's
basically the gist of things
and that is how mouse picking is going
to work so i hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please don't forget to
hit the like button below
thank you all for watching hope you've
enjoyed this series we're getting into
some some of the media stuff now don't
forget that you can help support the
series by going to patreon.com
slash the channel you'll get access to
like hazel dev and past live streams
where i work out this stuff and uh
there's lots of really exciting stuff
going on in hazel dev as well
check out those devlogs definitely if
you're interested in where this series
is eventually heading to hope you have
an amazing day and i will see you next
time goodbye
[Music]
you